[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv et 78 nous sommes le
jeudi 5 octobre et dans les titres de
l'actualité
la visite d'elizabeth borne à versailles
la ministre des transports s'est rendue
ce matin au centre de recherche et
d'innovation de bd comme là où se
développe la voiture du futur des
véhicules propres et connectée qui
fonctionne sans chauffeur nous étions
sur place
réduire de 30% le poids des déchets
jetés dans nos poubelles le tout sur six
mois objectifs du défi zéro déchet
lancée par l'association plaisir en
transition rencontres et ateliers
pratiques sont au programme le détail
dans ce journal avec camille trestel co
organisatrice de ce défi et puis une
fête en attendant la ryder cup 2018 golf
expérience se déroule ce samedi au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
festival pour faire connaître davantage
la discipline olympique et nous en
parlons avec xavier cuisinière ce chef
de projet ryder cup à saint quentin en
yvelines avant de débuter ce journal
l'information a été officialisée cet
après midi le professeur alain d'hui est
le nouveau président de l'université
versailles à saint quentin en yvelines
le conseil d'administration de
l'établissement l'a élu aujourd'hui il
remplace le professeur didier guillemot
qui a remis sa démission en septembre
pour raisons de santé
ces images maintenant ce matin trois
campements de roms ont été évacués par
la police nationale à saint quentin en
yvelines
plusieurs familles ont ainsi dû quitter
leur installation sur trappe et montigny
le bretonneux
elles ont été ensuite redirigés vers des
chambres d'hôtel en ile de france et ce
déplacement en dehors des yvelines faute
de place inquiète les quelques membres
des associations locales présents sur
place propos recueillis par nicolas
kirilow grâce il ya un jeune dont je
sais très bien qu'il a c'est un cdi donc
là on l'a empêché d'aller au boulot
j'espère qu'il va pas perdre son boulot
il y en a deux autres qui ont eu du mal
à trouver un travail qui depuis huit
jours en ont un
donc là aussi ils ont téléphoné en
disant on peut pas venir travailler mais
voilà ils vont être envoyées le ce qu'il
faut faire c'est ouvrir plus de places
d'hébergement dans le coin
pour justement les héberger et là où ils
ont une vie parce qu'ils ont vraiment
une vie ici un déplacement officiel
également à l'actualité de ce jeudi je
vous le disais dans les titres elisabeth
bornes en charge des transports ministre
en charge des transports s'est rendu à
versailles sur le site de bd comme elle
a pu assister à plusieurs présentations
et démonstrations autour des véhicules
du futur reportage de nicolas landry et
nicolas kirillovitch la ministre des
transports était accompagné d'un vice
président de la commission européenne
pour découvrir certains prototypes de
l'institut vd comme que ce soit la
voiture électrique qui se recharge toute
seule en roulant ou cette voiture
blanche prototype du transport à la
demande
autonome puis quand la mission a été
acceptée par le poste de commande
centralisé va venir se positionner ici
qui a beaucoup de territoires dans
lequel il faut tout simplement répondre
aux besoins des gens qui n'ont pas le
permis de conduire ou qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de conduire une voiture et
je pense que des solutions de ce type là
demain dans des zones peu denses
ça pourra tout à fait répondre à cet
enjeu de la mobilité pour chacun en
pleine assises nationales de la mobilité
cette visite visait aussi à saluer le
travail de l'institut versailles et vd
comme depuis sa création il ya trois ans
l'institut est devenu un leader européen
dans la recherche de solutions
innovantes pour les transports financée
par des acteurs de l'automobile les
différentes collectivités vd com dispose
aujourd'hui d'un budget annuel de 30
millions d'euros
les axes dans lesquelles on se dirige
sont clairement les axes qui sont
poussés à la fois par la france et par
l'europe c'est des axes de mobilité avec
plusieurs modes en même temps c'est des
axes d'efficience énergétique
c'est aussi des axes dans lequel le
véhicule autonome apporte un vrai plus
sur le transport à la demande pour
poursuivre son développement vd com
prévoit de s'installer l'an prochain
dans de nouveaux locaux à
versailles-satory et la venue de la
ministre des transports à versailles
était aussi l'occasion de clarifier
certains sujets et notamment celui de la
ligne 10
8 qui doit relier à l'horizon 2030
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles et des
rumeurs d'abandon du projet par le
gouvernement faute de financement
circulent depuis quelques semaines
elisabeth bande s'est voulue rassurante
sur le tracé du métro moins sur le
calendrier que les élus yvelinois
voudraient avancer à 2024 il n'est pas
question de remettre en cause les
trajets tels qu'ils ont été discutés
dans le cadre du grand paris comme pour
l'ensemble des infrastructures
on doit réfléchir à une programmation et
à des calendriers mais personne n'a
l'idée de remettre en cause les trajets
le réseau du grand paris tel qu'il a été
arrêté donc la ligne 18 arrivera dans
les yvelines
une pétition en ligne vient d'ailleurs
d'être lancé pour sauver la ligne 18 à
l'initiative de saint quentin en
yvelines versailles grand parc ou encore
de la cci 78 transport toujours 158
lignes de bus améliorée dans la région
ile-de-france mobilité vient de dévoiler
son plan de restructuration à saint
quentin en yvelines le réseau stibus est
concerné par cette modification dans le
concret l'offre est revu à la hausse sur
l'ouest du territoire plus généralement
ce sont des passages de bus
supplémentaires pour faire face aux
surcharges
elle vient de se terminer la deuxième
édition du sky business day se dérouler
aujourd'hui au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines évènement pour
promouvoir l'attractivité du territoire
et accompagner les entreprises dans leur
développement près de 600 participants
grands groupes donneurs d'ordres pme tpe
et start up étaient sur place premiers
bilans collectés sur place par aurélie
ronces patrick jacques de dixmude et
axel de bell 15 % d'augmentation en
terme de fréquentation des rendez vous
de qualité
nous avons la foi des entreprises qui
étaient déjà présentes à une manière qui
sont revenus preuve que l'événement leur
permet de nouer de nouveaux contacts
mais aussi de nouvelles entreprises
des grands groupes qui sont encore plus
présents que l'année dernière donc
autant d'éléments qui nous font dire que
on l'évaluera bien sûr mais que d'ores
et déjà on peut considérer que cette
édition est de nouveau un succès à
l'expérimentation a été lancée en juin à
magny les hameaux les élèves de l'école
élémentaire à louise weiss tri est
désormais leur plateau à la cantine
sensibilisation pour lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire
un projet en partenariat avec la commune
les associations et amap ainsi que le
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse et mélanie poquet et
michael et me doro dressant un premier
bilan de cette opération
alors que va-t-il mettre dans le conte
proches dans la poubelle à compost est
quelque chose que tu peux y mettre mes
réflexes ne sont pas encore naturel pour
cette élève de l'école louise weiss
depuis le début du mois de juin les
écoliers tri ce qu'ils restent dans leur
assiette ce domaine et la nature j'adore
la nature
j'ai fait très attention à bayonne pour
les déchets bah ça leur permet de faire
moins de travail l'école élémentaire est
la première des neuf établissements de
la commune a testé cette expérience une
sensibilisation qui se fait avec les
élèves les enseignants des associations
manic oise et les services municipaux
c'est en fait la plus grosse école de la
commune
elle comprend onze classes et à la
restauration scolaire il ya 245 élèves
donc et un comptage a été fait et en
moyenne ya quinze kilos de déchets par
jour
ces actions comme beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs que l'on mène dans notre
école s'inscrivent dans notre projet
d'école dans ce projet d'école il est
prévu un volet agenda 21
et donc nous sommes amenés en place et
des enfants à les sensibiliser sur tous
les enjeux écologiques aux enjeux de
protection de la planète
une protection de l'environnement est
également sur le développement durable
les restes sont ensuite jetés dans des
composteurs installé dans la cour en
début de semaine un compost qui sera
utilisé pour les espaces verts de la
ville
chaque jour nous jetons en moyenne 1 kg
de déchets selon l' agence de
l'environnement et de maîtrise de
l'énergie
pourtant seulement 20% de ces déchets
sont recyclables le reste polluent la
nature réduire sa production de déchets
c'est l'objectif du déficit zéro déchet
à plaisir bonsoir camille christelle
pendant que j'avais j'avais perdu autres
n'ont qu'à me christelle vous êtes la
coprésidente de plaisir en transition
c'est une association qui organise ce
défi réduire 30% de ces déchets sur six
mois on en parle dans un instant
peut-être déjà un mot sur l'association
quelles sont ses missions alors plaisir
aux transitions et l'association qui qui
est dans le groupe des villes et des
territoires de transition qui a été
créée par rob hawkins et l'idée en fait
des associations aux transitions c'est
de prendre conscience qu'un jour ou
l'autre le pétrole va manquer et que si
on se prépare pas dès maintenant le choc
va être très très dur et donc
le pétrole est devenu tellement
tellement on a du mal en patience et
voilà c'est ça que quand faite sur tous
les sujets il est là donc ça peut être
l'alimentation ça peut être le
déplacement ça peut être il ya plein
plein de raisons qui expliquent qu'on a
le compte utilisé du pétrole et donc il
faut dès maintenant commencer à remettre
replace des des activités plus locale
donc plaisir aux transitions essaye au
niveau de plaisir de développer
différents projets qui est de tous les
citoyens à se projeter à mettre en place
des solutions alors de nombreux défis
sans déchantent et elle lancé en france
pourquoi on proposait un également un
plaisir parce qu'il n'y en avait pas à
plaisir que par définition toutes les
actions d'aider les associations de
transition sont locales il ya
effectivement un défi qui se lancent un
millier d amour avec la lèque il ya des
projets à très grande échelle effective
au qui se lance dans un certain nombre
de villes d'où un plaisir ont des
équipes de la commission de réduction
des déchets qui était très motivé pour
faire ce genre de choses donc si à la
motivation pourquoi pas le faire et
baisser sa consommation de déchets de
30% six mois où s est réellement
possible lors de pluies gestes au
quotidien
oui alors quand on analyse la
composition d'une poubelle on se rend
compte qu'en fait il ya une grosse
partie qui qui est de fait de déchets
organiques
donc on l'a vu dans le reportage ce
tableau déjà à mettre en place du
compost on peut au brevet réduire sa
poubelle de 20 à 30%
donc effectivement ça peut être assez
facile à tout le monde n'a pas accès à
un compost mais on peut effectivement
par claude petit geste
le réduire
ces déchets du compost peut être pas
aussi également au quotidien comme petit
geste par exemple fabriquer si des
choses soi-même des des produits
cosmétiques des produits d'entretien
également ça peut être aussi ça
absolument tout à fait ça peut être
aussi la manière dont on fait ses
courses privilégié au général les
circuits courts c'est le meilleur moyen
parce que on dévie tout le suremballage
qui est l'apanage de l'agro alimentaire
industriel alors ce défi sans déchet ce
fait par équipe vous lancé par équipes
pourquoi c'est plus facile dans la
motivation peut-être d'être par équipes
l'idée qu'il ya derrière aussi c'est de
garder la convivialité que ce ça va être
déjà assez difficile de se remettre en
question et de changer ses habitudes
donc autant que ce soit fait
effectivement dans la joie et la bonne
humeur
on veut faire un défi convivial avec des
rencontres régulières finir avec une
fête
effectivement il faut qu'on soit
ensemble en dira plus loin d'ailleurs vu
pendant ces six mois vous avez proposé
aux participants des solutions clés en
main il ya plusieurs ateliers qui vont
être proposées pendant ce défi sans
déchets tout à fait on va rythmer le
défi de qui dure six mois avec une
rencontre à peu près tous les bois donc
sur des thématiques diverses et variées
au conte comment ça comment faire ses
courses
quand est-ce que effectivement ça sera
sans doute c'est sans doute dans la
cuisine quand généré le plus de déchets
il y aura une petite un petit atelier
sur noël
al'approche des fêtes de noël on va bien
sûr parler du compost effectivement les
les cosmétiques les produits légers
intéressant noël ça peut être fabriqué
ces décorations faire aussi des cadeaux
enfin fabriquer ses propres cadeaux
comment aborder autrement
l'idée de noël qui est qui génère
énormément de déchet d'accord donc vêtu
vont se poser la question de comment on
pourrait faire autrement effectivement
pourquoi pas offrir des baux pour ou
fabriquer ses propres cadeaux ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué alors dernière
chose il nous reste très peu de temps
pour ceux qui sont intéressés il ya une
réunion d'information est organisée ce
samedi à plaisir ça se passe où
exactement et à quelle heure alors je
préfère pas donner l'adresse à la
télévision il faudrait envoyer un mail à
plaisir aux transitions et gmail.com ou
donnera tous les détails
donc c'est samedi c'est à 16h et ça
durera une heure une heure et demie le
retrouver plus d'informations il ya le
blog de plaisir en transition qui
s'affiche le site internet merci
camille a créé c'est d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle vous êtes la
coprésidente de plaisir en transition
l'association qui propose donc ce défi à
zéro déchet 6 mois pour réduire 30% de
sa production de déchets merci à d'avoir
été avec nous toujours toujours à
plaisir ou ce week-end vous pourrez
aussi peut-être trouvé votre compagnon à
quatre pattes
le refuge spa de la ville organise ses
portes ouvertes samedi et dimanche de
10h à 18h 250 ch à une centaine de
chiens seront à adopter la capacité du
site qui est plein en ce moment après un
été une nouvelle fois marquée par les
abandons
écoutez la responsable du refuge au
micro au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
cette année on a été quand même
malheureusement encore très sollicités
pour les abandons on a eu beaucoup de
rentrer de chiens et de chats
donc ça a été assez difficile les
adoptions ont heureusement repris depuis
la rentrée depuis début septembre
donc heureusement on a fait quand même
adopté beaucoup d'animaux
malheureusement pas encore assez
puisqu'on est toujours dans la tente en
fait de sortir des animaux de fourrière
donc pour ça on a vraiment besoin de
faire des adoptions pour libérer la
place pour les prochains pour adopter
une participation de 150 euros vous sera
demandée pour les chats frais de
vétérinaire inclus 250 euros pour un
chien 300 euros pour un chiot
c'est jusqu'au 21 octobre la fête de la
science à saint quentin en yvelines se
poursuit des rencontres scientifiques
des expériences et des ateliers sont
proposés sur tout le territoire et
notamment ce week end
cette semaine à la médiathèque de là
derrière une dizaine d'enfants ont
travaillé sur l'illusion optique
reportages des orignaux 11 et camille
lambert
là ces deux bandes noires lever la main
ceux qui pensent que cette bande est
plus petite que celle là malgré les
apparences ces deux traits noirs font
bel et bien la même taille reconnaître
et comprendre une illusion d'optique
un exercice pas toujours évident surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'expliquer des get
rich compose de voir mais en fait non
quelque chose que tu vois où tu sens où
tu entends mais qui n'est pas vrai
illusion d'optique contrairement à ce
qu'on pense pas une illusion créée par
l'oeil c'est une illusion qu'on voit
mais qui crée par le cerveau justement
le cerveau se tromper créer une logique
là où il n'y en a pas c'est là que
naissent justement les illusions
d'optique
parmi la dizaine d'enfants participants
à cet atelier certains découvraient pour
la première fois ce phénomène et rien de
mieux qu'une petite mise en pratique
pour s'en rendre compte
on termine l'atelier par la fabrication
d'une chambre dame qui est donc une
illusion je pas si vous connaissez c'est
vraiment on veut faire entrer deux
personnes dans une salle qu'en mai à les
deux personnes au bout il y en a une qui
paraît démesuré mangande par rapport à
l'autre parce qu'en fait la forme de la
salle n'est pas vraiment celle d'une
salle mais notre oeil la perçoit comme
tel et donc se consacrer quelque chose
dans le cadre de la fête de la science
de nombreux ateliers sont proposés
jusqu'au 21 octobre une exposition manip
sur la lumière est actuellement à
découvrir à la médiathèque de la
verrière yvelines qui attend
impatiemment la ryder cup 2018 la coupe
du monde de golf se déroule dans moins
d'un an au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et justement
le site saint quentinois accueil
le golf expérience samedi à de 14h à
minuit bonsoir à exhaler cuisinière ce
chef de projet ryder cup à saint quentin
en yvelines vous êtes pleinement dans le
dossier de cette ryder cup golf
expérience qui remplace l'ancien golf
festival et qui a pour but de faire
connaître davantage cette discipline
olympique pourquoi exactement donc une
expérience comme vous avez pu le dire
qui est peut-être déjà connu certains
saint quentinois est certes un
francilien soit la forme de gaulle
festival qui était le rendez vous
incontournable du golfe sur le
territoire aujourd'hui on relance sous
un nouveau nom à la proche de la ryder
cup un an avant cet événement
exceptionnel on l'a nommé golf
expérience pour vraiment partager cette
expérience auprès du plus grand nombre
aussi bien les débutants que les
golfeurs initiés est vraiment les
animations pour tout le monde ça se
passe de 14 heures à minuit aussi bien
des animations que des initiations des
jeux concours
le fameux coach de nuit également qu'une
expérience dans l'est dans un instant va
pouvoir en discuter mais surtout gulf
expérience je dors je vais pas non plus
spoiler la suite de l'interview mais
c'est le lancement de notre village
ryder cup en avant première qui sera un
village éphémère et ambulants qui va se
déplacer sur les douze communes de
l'agglomération
exact c'est la ryder cup exactement
pendant un an on va être sur tout le
territoire et on va parler ryder cup aux
saint quentinois vraiment gros déjà les
sensibiliser à l'accueil de cet
événement grandiose un troisième
événement très médiatisé du monde mais
aussi voilà l'or l'or et c'est de créer
ce sentiment de fierté d'appartenance à
une terre d'accueil de grands événements
sportifs internationaux redorer aussi
peut-être l'image du golf on a peut-être
à tort on le présente comme un sport
élitiste et c'est vrai que c'est une
image réelle en france qui a cette image
élitiste alors que dans les pays anglo
saxons et les etats unis c'est vraiment
un sport très populaire
d'ailleurs on peut voir des images de la
ryder cup d'alliance sur télé 78 on en a
vu régulièrement
c'est un sport très populaire où les
gens viennent déguisés maquillés avec
leur klaxon donc c'est vraiment ce qu'on
va essayer de démontrer aux saint
quentinois grâce justement à tous ce
plan d'action très dense pendant un an
on va aller à la rencontre aussi bien du
grand public et des entreprises pour
leur parler de la razer quelques convois
à l'image d'un d'ailleurs des images de
la précédente édition qui était aux
états unis oui l'idée c'est que ce soit
quelque chose de convivial convié petits
et grands novices comme expert
expérience exactement donc aux
expériences de 14h à minuit samedi de la
restauration sur place pour justement
rester toute la journée en plus la météo
annonce plutôt un beau temps donc ça
c'est quand même une très bonne nouvelle
donc aussi bien pour les débutants on
aura des pros qui les accompagneront
pour leur expliquer ce qu'est le golf
comment on tient un club etc il y aura
également des ateliers de
perfectionnement pour les golfeurs
justement initié pour qu'ils apprennent
peut-être réalisé un meilleur geste et
s'améliorer encore et toujours
parcours pour tous les goûts
d'initiation ds d'initiation et aussi
pour les gens plus expérimentés
exactement comme vous le disiez alors
vous en avez parlé également d'une
session nocturne qui est tapé des balles
fluorescentes
exactement c'est quelque chose d'assez
inédit donc on était déjà présent lors
de golf festival qu'on relance
évidemment cette année la possibilité
déjà de jouer sur un parcours avec des
balles fluorescentes et un parcours tout
en tout illuminé d'accord également le
practice de nuit avec un dj set en live
un peu électro lounge pour vraiment
avoir cette ambiance très conviviale
finalement et casser cette image de
sport élitiste et des cadeaux à la clé
beaucoup de cadeaux beaucoup de jeux
concours toute la journée également tous
les visiteurs repartiront avec un goodie
ryder cup pour pour justement repartir
avec une belle image de cette journée on
a moins d'un an de cette compétition
acquis et se déroulera du 25 au 30
septembre 2018 on est allé à l'idée
c'est de faire monter
excusez-moi l'expression mais monter la
sauce exactement ça jusqu'à exactement
ça on va essayer de faire monter la
sauce comme vous dites si bien là on est
à peu près un an de la ryder cup et
commence le 25 donc c'est on est un peu
un peu moins d'un an le comment
oui nous cet événement du 7 octobre ces
notes one year to go à celui de la de
l'organisateur l'european tour aura lieu
une semaine après le but c'est vraiment
justement de sensibiliser les gens à la
ryder cup et nous c'est surtout le point
de départ de toutes nos actions
promotionnelles tout un calendrier qui
se met en place pendant un an pendant un
an on va vraiment occupé l'espace
mais même pas qu'ils pas que nous
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toutes les
communes toutes les communes de
l'agglomération vont vraiment être
actrice de l'accueil de l'événement et
ne serait-ce que notre village ryder cup
éphémère ambulants va se balader donc
sous forme de road show pendant un an
aujourd'hui on a à peu près une
vingtaine d'événements ryder cup qui
vous sont répertoriés sur 11 communes
très vite donc c'est quand même un grand
succès en perspective les envois que
l'engouement en plus c est grand dans
ces communes à des conteurs des des
comptes à rebours qui ont été longuement
commentée par exemple voisins le
bretonneux exactement
voisins-le-bretonneux vous aviez
également le compte à rebours en gare de
saint quentin en yvelines à montigny
vous en avez d'autres sur toutes les
communes qui sont en train des stands
installés
également on est en train de marquer
d'habiller tous les les bâtiments sur
les hôtels de vie où les équipements
sportifs pour vraiment imprégné le
territoire de de cette fierté
d'accueillir ce grand événement il ya eu
le pari sladen championship la semaine
dernière là c'est un fait ce golf
expérience d'ici la ryder cup
quels sont les événements phares qu'on
pourra pour avoir alors il y en avoir
beaucoup en tout cas que saint quentin
en yvelines va porter alors bien
évidemment je vais paraître village
ryder cup qui pendant plus d'un an
nous on va également organiser des
tournois ils sortent de ryder cup pour
les scolaires
ryder cup pour les étudiants ryder cup
pour les entreprises également et ryder
cup pour les saint quentinois au global
on va également à la halle et essayer de
toucher un public jeune saint quentinois
connectés avait beaucoup de jeux
concours et jeux un jeu très viral sur
le réseaux sociaux bien évidemment le
h1n1 open de france 2018 qui aura lieu
où saint quentin en yvelines sera très
présent aussi bien pour parler aux
entreprises du territoire et même en
dehors que pour les enfants sur le
village merchandising golf expérience
qui se déroule ce samedi au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
animations qui sont gratuites ce merci
et xavier kuhn
c'est d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes chef de projet ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup et rendez vous samedi et
plus d'infos sur le site internet 1 qui
s'est affichée en bas de l'écran avant
de refermer ce journal on vous en
parlait dans le 7-8 culture le festival
de la bd de but que se tient ce week-end
et parmi les auteurs présents et rock le
papa des profs cela fait 17 ans qu'il
imagine ces histoires d'enseignants
désabusé parfois loufoques et d'élèves
peut motiver à bondues qui l'a fait
d'abord étape à versailles camille
lambert l'a rencontré un prof d'histoire
obsédé par napoléon une prof d'anglais
un brin acariâtre et le cancre boulard
depuis 2000 ils n'ont pas pris une ride
des personnages devenus cultes au fil
des années et qui ont même fait l'objet
de deux films en 2013 et 2014
un succès difficile à expliquer pour son
créateur au début c'était c'était
justement le thème qui posait problème
c'est à dire que nous quand on a vu des
éditeurs on nous a dit les enfants même
si je n'ai pas que des lecteurs qui sont
des enfants monique quand les enfants de
l'école n'ont pas envie de retomber
dedans donc ça marchera jamais je pense
moi plutôt que ça a marché parce que
justement les gamins s'y retrouver je
suis content de voir des gens de 25 ans
qui effectivement me disent que je
continue voilà j'ai acheté le dernier
alors je pense qu'il voit plus il voit
pas la même chose que ce qu'ils voyaient
2 à 11 12 ans mais ce qui compte c'est
qu'ils soient fidèles quoi ça fait
plaisir
échanger avec les lecteurs un jeu auquel
et rock se prête volontiers
il a même aidé à élaborer le nouvel
agenda de l'agglomération versailles
grand parc avec des enfants depuis
plusieurs années il participe au
festival de la bd de but qu il sera
présent pour la 24e édition des 7 et 8
octobre prochains
j'y vais chaque année depuis déjà un
certain temps où elle c'est assez sympa
parce que les gens je retrouve j'aime
bien les gens qu il
qu'ils mettent en forme qui s'en occupe
il n'y a pas tellement d'autres
occasions devant le public que dans les
festivals de bd donc
celui ci comme les autres évidemment
plus être public pouvons avoir un public
un petit peu varié et ça c'est
intéressant pour nous l'occasion de
faire découvrir le dix neuvième tome de
la série sorti le mois dernier
même après 17 ans les profs ne sont pas
encore prêts à quitter leur lycée c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal reportages et
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 vendredi vous
retrouvez le 7-8 l'hebdo de nicolas
kirillovitch et nous on se retrouve
lundi pour une nouvelle enfants une
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]